SESSION IS CALLED TO ORDER.
THE ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN SESSION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANT ARMS WILL PREPARE THE
CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ACOSTA AGUIAR-CURRY ALLEN
ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW BLOOM [inaudible]
BONTA BROUGH [inaudible]
BURKE CABALLERO CALDERON
CARRILLO CERVANTES CHAU CHAVEZ
CHEN.
DAVID CHIU.
CHOI KANSEN CHU COOLEY COOPER
[inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM DALLY.
DALY EGGMAN FLORA.
FONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GABRIEL
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ FLETCHER
GRAY GRAYSON HARPER HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KAMLAGER-DOVE KILEY LACKEY
LEVINE LIMON OWN.
LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN.
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
QUIRK QUIRK SILVA REYES REVISE
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO.
STEINORTH STONE.
THURMOND [inaudible]
TING VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
IN THE GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND
FOR TODAY'S INVOCATION.
WHICH WILL BE OFFERED BY OUR
ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN REVEREND BOB
OSHITA.
REVEREND.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
SHOWING FRONT SHOWING BACK.
MAPLE LEAVES CALL.
A SECOND REFLECTION ON THE HAIKU
BY POET YUKON TYPE WHO.
WRITTEN TWO HUNDRED YEARS AGO.
IN OUR MINDS AYE WE CAN
VISUALIZE THE AUTUMN COLORED
LEAVES FLUTTERING DOWN FROM THE
TREES IN A COOL BREEZE.
THERE IS A SENSE THAT THINGS ARE
JUST AS THE SHOULD BE.
WHEN AUTUMN COMES THE LEAVES
FALL GENTLY TO THE GROUND?
THEY TWIRL THEN FLOAT SHOWING
FRONT.
AND SHOWING BACK. TO OFTEN WE
HUMAN BEINGS FLOAT THROUGH LIFE.
ONLY WANTING TO SHOW OUR
FRIENDS.
OUR GOOD SIDE.
BEFORE MY WIFE PATTY FIRED ME AS
OUR GARDENER.
THEY WERE OFTEN HECTIC WEEKS
WHEN WE FELT THEY WERE JUST NOT
ENOUGH HOURS IN THE DAY.
AT SUCH TIMES I WOULD CARVE OUT
THIRTY MINUTES AND MORE ONLY OUR
FRONT YARD [inaudible]
WHY?
BECAUSE THAT WAS THE PART THAT
PEOPLE WOULD SEE.
ONCE PATTY SAID IT MY COSMETIC
MONNING.
WHAT A SAD HIGH A CREW WOULD BE
WRITTEN ABOUT YOU?
THEN SMILING SHE SAID.
SHOWING FRONT SHOWING FRONT BOB
WELCH DOES TRIES TO LIVE HIS
LIFE [inaudible]
WE LEFT.
BUT SHE WAS RIGHT.
ANYWAY.
I AM TRULY INFERIOR TO THE MAPLE
LEAFS OF DEAL KINDS HAIKU.
AND FROM THIS HAIKU I HAVE MUCH
TO LEARN AND ASPIRE.
TO I MUST TRY TO LIVE BEING BY
ONE'S TRUE SELF.
WITH WISDOM EYES OPEN.
LET US TRY TO LIVE IN HARMONY
WITH NATURE.
GRATEFUL FOR THE GENTLE LESSONS
SHE IS ALWAYS SHARING.
NUMBER ONE YOU KNOW WITH
KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE BEYOND
WORDS.
I AM BY NATURE MEANS STANDING
FOR THE SLICE FLAG SALUTE WHICH
WILL BE OFFERED TODAY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARK STONE.
MEMBERS AND VISITORS.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE HIGH.
STATES OF AMERICA.
AND TO THE REPUBLIC.
STANDS.
IT IS AVAILABLE.
GAYNESS.
YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY AUGUST NINTH
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE ASSEMBLY MET
AT NINE A. M. ON BILL KEVIN
MULLIN SPEAKER PRO TEM OF THE
ASSEMBLY PRESIDING CHEAPER EVEN
ARTICLES NOW THROUGH THEM MOVES
AND MISTER LACKEY SECONDS OF THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL.
BECAUSE WITH PRESENTATIONS OF
PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ.
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
FROM THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
TODAY'S ABSENCES FOR LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVID
CHIU ASSEMBLY MEMBER SUSAN
EGGMAN ASSEMBLY MEMBER SHARON
QUIRK SILVA. FOR ILLNESS IAN
CALDERON. FOR PERSONAL BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARC STEINORTH
.
MISTER BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR MOTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND.
ASSEMBLY RULE ONE EIGHTEEN A TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY TO
HAVE GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON
THE FLOOR TODAY HIS GUESTS WILL
BE SEATED AT HIS DESK.
WITHOUT OBJECTION MR MCCARTY YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I KNOW
WE'RE NOT DOING A LOT OF THIS
TODAY BUT TODAY IS A SPECIAL DAY
WITH.
TWO OUTSTANDING DISTRICT SEVEN
CONSTITUENTS THEY CAN'T VOTE FOR
ME HERE TODAY BUT THEY WANT TO
VOTE ON A FEW BILLS --
THEY ARE CELEBRATING THEIR TENTH
BIRTHDAY TODAY.
SO PLEASE I WELCOME --
MY GUESS WHO WISH TO HAPPY
BIRTHDAY TO VICTORIA AND BARBARA
MCCARTY
.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTIONS.
THANK YOU MA'AM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND JOINT RULE
SIXTY TWO A THE FILE NOTICE
REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE. TO
MEET UPON ADJOURNMENT OF SESSION
TODAY TO HEAR SCR ONE FIFTY NINE
BATES WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
RE REFER S. B. EIGHT FOUR FOR
MINING AND SB EIGHT FOUR FIVE
MINING FROM THE RULES COMMITTEE
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE SIXTY NINE
TO ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM TO
TO TAKE UP LATE AMENDMENTS TO
ITEM NUMBER.
THREE TWENTY SEVEN S. B. EIGHT
TWENTY A WIENER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF WALDRON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED WHO WE OPPOSE
THAT MOTION AND ASK FOR ROLL
CALL.
THANK YOU THIS IS NOT DEBATABLE.
IS THEIR SECOND ASSEMBLY.
SO REMEMBER DOLLY SECONDS.
SORRY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON
SECONDS.
MADAM CLERK WAS OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
TO MISS WALDRON IS ASKING FOR
THE NO VOTE MISTER --
BONTA IS ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE
OF ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
BUT A QUICK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
WRONG TIED THE BOATS EYES FORTY
THREE KNOWS.
TWENTY ONE THE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED [inaudible]
HEY
.
MEMBERS PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TOO I
AM RESCINDING MY PREVIOUS RE
REFER ALL OF AB FIFTEEN TWENTY
NINE BY THURMAN. TO THE
INVOLVEMENT OF SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS COMMITTEE THE BILL
SHALL BE RETURNED TO THE
UNFINISHED BUSINESS FILE.
ALSO PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO I AM
REVISING THE RIVER FOR ALL OF AB
TEN SIX TO LEVINE. TO INCLUDE RE
REFERRING THE BILL TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AFTER
IT IS HEARD BY THE HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
AND I AM REVISING THE RIVER FOR
ALL OF S. B. FOR SIXTY FIVE
JACKSON TO INCLUDE RE REFER IN
THE BILL TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE AFTER IT IS HEARD BY
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
SEVENTY SEVEN POINT YOU ARE
MARIE REFERRING THE FOLLOWING
BILLS TO COMMITTEE ITEM FIFTEEN
AB FIFTEEN A SEVENTY THREE BLOOM
TO WATER PARKS AND WILDLIFE.
ITEM TWENTY THREE A. B. THIRTY
ONE OF THIRTY FIVE BY FRAZIER TO
TRANSPORTATION ITEM SIXTY TWO AB
SIXTEEN NINETEEN BY BERMAN
JUDICIARY.
ITEM.
NINETY A. B. EIGHT TWENTY NINE
BY CHIU TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT ITEM
NINETY TWO A. B. FOURTEEN TWENTY
THREE BY CHIU TO NATURAL
RESOURCES.
ITEM ONE OF FOR A BI TO TWENTY
THREE THIRTY RIGHT BIGELOW TO
TRANSPORTATION.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
FILE ITEM OF ONE THROUGH.
THREE NOT A QUICKLY ISRAEL.
ASSUMING CAR RESOLUTION TO
SAMPLE EIGHT TWENTY TWO AND
SEVERAL FIVE GO.
TO ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
FILE ITEMS FOUR THROUGH ONE
TWENTY SIX PASS AND RETAIN FILE
ITEMS ONE THIRTY THROUGH WHEN
THIRTY THREE OUR CONTINUED.
FILE ITEMS ONE THIRTY FOUR THREE
ONE THIRTY ONE FORTY THREE PASS
AND RETAIN [inaudible]
FILE I
MEN MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING.
TO DOWN ON THE DAILY FILE.
WE'RE GOING TO BE TAKING UP ITEM
OF ONE FORTY ONE AB TWENTY THREE
OH THREE MATTER QUICKLY.
THREE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
OH THREE WITH AMENDMENTS BY SOME
REMEMBER THURMAN'S.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THURMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER --
AND COLLEAGUES I RISE TO PRESENT
AMENDMENTS.
TWENTY THREE OH THREE OF THESE
AMENDMENTS ARE ALLOW US TO
PROVIDE MORE INVESTMENTS IN
COMPUTER SCIENCE SPORTS STUDENTS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON THESE AMENDMENTS.
SUMMER WALDRON YOU'RE RECOGNIZED
WE OPPOSE THE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU SAYING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE MEADOW PARK WAS OPEN
THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ON THE ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FORTY ONE AT NO.
TWENTY ONE THE ITEM IS BACKED UP
TO PRETTY BACK ON FILE.
MOVING AHEAD IN THE FILE TO ITEM
TWO HUNDRED S. B. THIRTEEN
THIRTY THREE MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN THIRTY
THREE WITH AMENDMENTS BY SOME
MEMBER GLORIA.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT
AMENDMENTS TO SP TEN SEVENTY
EIGHT THE SENATE TRANSPORTATION
AND HOUSING COMMITTEES HOUSING
OMNIBUS BILL.
THIS BILL MAKES TECHNICAL
CHANGES TO SECTIONS OF HOUSING
LAW THESE AMENDMENTS ADDRESS
CHAPTER IN OUT ISSUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON THESE AMENDMENTS.
SOME MEMBER WALDRON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED UP WE OPPOSE THE
AMENDMENTS.
SEEING NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MADAM CLERK WAS OPEN THE
ROLL-ON ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS.
VOTE
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE
THE ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES AYE
AYES FORTY ONE KNOWS.
TWENTY THREE SORRY TWENTY TO THE
AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE BILL
IS OUT OF PRINT AND BACK ON
FILE.
MOVING TO ITEM TO TWENTY EIGHT
SP ONE EIGHTY THREE MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ONE EIGHTY THREE
WITH AMENDMENTS BY SOME THE
NUMBER ARAMBULA.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
AMENDMENTS THE SENATE BILL ONE
EIGHTY THREE REMOVED THE
ORIGINAL BILL CONTENT.
THE LANGUAGE ADDED DECLARES
IMMIGRATION STATUS AS A
PROTECTED STATUS UNDER
CALIFORNIA'S EQUITY IN HIGHER
EDUCATION ACT.
AND INCLUDES ONE CLARIFYING
AMENDMENT AT THE REQUEST OF THE
ADMINISTRATION.
THIS BODY HAS ALREADY VOTED FOR
A NEARLY IDENTICAL MEASURE
EARLIER THIS WEEK I ASK THAT
THESE AMENDMENTS BE ADOPTED AND
THE BILL BE SENT OUT TO PRINT AT
THIS TIME.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WALDRON WE OPPOSE
THE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU MADAM CLERK YOU MAY
OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED
VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAME CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE AND HOW THE VOTES AYE AYES
FORTY ONE NO.
TWENTY THE AMENDMENTS ARE
ADOPTED THE BILL IS OUT OF PRINT
IMPACT ON FILE MOVING TO ITEM TO
NINETY EIGHT S. B. THREE FORTY
NINE MADAME QUICKLY ST.
SENATE BILL THREE FORTY NINE
WITH AMENDMENTS BY SOME THE
MEMBER GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
AS A MEMBER GONZALEZ FLETCHER
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
AMENDMENTS TO SP THREE FORTY
NINE REMOVE ALL OF THE ORIGINAL
BILL CONTENTS IN OUT THE
PROTECTION FROM CIVIL REST FOR
INDIVIDUALS AT OUR COURTHOUSES.
CHOOSE OUR PASSES FLOOR
PREVIOUSLY I SAID THESE
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED THE BILL BE
PLACED BACK ON THE FILE.
THANK YOU.
AS A MEMBER WALDRON WE OPPOSE
THIS AMENDMENT THANK YOU WITHOUT
MADAM PRECLUDES OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM COOKIE MAKE CLOTHES THE
ROLE ENTIRELY THE VOTES EYES
THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS TWENTY ONE
THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE
BILL IS OUT OF PRINT AND BACK ON
FILE.
MOVING TO ITEM THREE ELEVEN S.
B. ONE SIXTY EIGHT MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ONE SIXTY EIGHT WITH
THE MANAGED BY SOMETHING MEMBER
BLOOM.
THANK YOU IS A MEMBER BLOOM YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER.
THESE AMENDMENTS CREATE MINIMUM
CONTENT STANDARDS FOR PLASTIC
BEVERAGE CONTAINERS THEREBY
MAXIMIZING THE USE OF RECYCLED
MATERIAL AND BEVERAGE CONTAINERS
AND HELPING. TO BUILD AND
SUPPORT THE STATE'S DOMESTIC
MARKET FOR RECYCLED MATERIALS
THE AMENDMENT STRENGTHEN THE
ENFORCEMENT PROVISIONS BY MAKING
IT A PER DAY PENALTY.
CREATING AN INCENTIVE FOR
COMPANIES TO INCORPORATE MORE
RECYCLED MATERIAL IN THEIR
BEVERAGE CONTAINERS I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK U. S. SOME A MEMBER
WALDRON WE OPPOSE THE AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU MADAM CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
REQUIRES A MAJORITY OF THOSE
PRESENT AND VOTING.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
BUT IT TOOK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE AND HOW THE VOTES ICE
THIRTY SIX KNOWS TWENTY TO THE
AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE BILL
IS OUT OF PRINT AND BACK ON
FILE.
MOVING TO ITEM THREE SEVENTEEN
S. B. FOUR FIFTY TWO MADAM
QUICKLY THREE SENATE BILL FOUR
FIFTY TWO WITH AMENDMENTS BY
SOMEONE MEMBER GLORIA.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT AMENDMENTS TO SP FOUR
FIFTY TWO BY SENATOR GLAZER
THESE AMENDMENTS LAVA MOVE THE
SUNSET EXTENSION FOR PLASTIC
MARKET DEVELOPMENT CLAIM
PAYMENTS AND CONFORM DEPENDING
TRAILER BILLS.
I ADDED TAKE BACK EXEMPTION FOR
SMALL STORES OF LESS THAN FIVE
THOUSAND SQUARE FEET.
ALLOW INSTEAD OF REQUIRING CAO
RECYCLE TO WITHHOLD LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PAYMENTS FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE ACTED TO CLOSE
RECYCLING CENTERS IN THEIR
JURISDICTIONS.
AND LASTLY PROVIDE GUIDANCE
LANGUAGE TO COWER CYCLE FOR
DEVELOPING THEIR GUIDELINES FOR
WITHHOLDING PAYMENTS I ASK THESE
MEN IT'S VIDAK THAT THE BILL BE
PLACED OUT TO PRINT IN PLACE
BACK ON THE FILE.
THINK YOU SUMMER WALDRON WE
OPPOSE THE AMENDMENTS.
METACRITIC MAY OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES ICE
FORTY TWO KNOWS TWENTY TO THE
AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE BILL
IS OUT OF PRINT AND BACK ON
FILE.
MOVING TO I DON'T WANNA SORRY
ITEM A THREE FORTY FOUR SP TEN
TWENTY NINE MADAM QUICKLY THREE
SIMPLE TEN TWENTY NINE WITH THE
MOMENT BY SOMETHING NUMBER
WOULD.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF SO
REMEMBER WHAT YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER --
THE TODAY PRESENTING HAVE FOR
AMENDMENTS AS AS BE TEN TWENTY
NINE PLEASE NOTE THE THE BOTTOM
IS VOTERS ONLY ON THE AMENDMENTS
THE BILL WHICH PROVIDE FUNDING
UPON AGENCY APPROVAL FOR THE
ACQUISITION OF FREIGHT RIGHTS.
FOR THE NORTHWEST PACIFIC
RAILROAD COMPANY BY SOME A MAN
MARIN AREA RAIL TRANSIT.
RESPECT ASK YOUR AYE VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU SO MEMBER
WALDRON.
WE OPPOSE THE AMENDMENTS.
BUT A QUICK YOU MAY OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS BOTH THE DESIRE
TO VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES AYE
AYES FORTY FIVE NO TWENTY THE
AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE BILL
IS OUT OF PRINT AND BACK ON
FILE.
MOVING TO ITEM THREE EIGHTY SIX
SB THIRTEEN THIRTY FIVE MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN THIRTY FIVE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME REMEMBER
BLOOM.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM
YOUR RECOGNIZE YOU MADAM SPEAKER
THESE AMENDMENTS TO S. B.
THIRTEEN THIRTY FIVE BY SENATOR
ALLEN ADDRESS CONCERNS.
BY REMOVING THE LIST OF APPROVED
ITEMS IN THE BILL AND INSTEAD
TAKING MATERIAL NEUTRAL
APPROACH.
THE AMENDMENTS CALLING CAL
RECYCLED TO DETERMINE WHICH
TYPES OF FOOD PACKING ARE
RECYCLABLE COMPOSTABLE OR
REUSABLE SOMETHING WE SHOULD ALL
KNOW.
AND THEREFORE CAN BE USED AT
STATE PARKS BEACHES ANOTHER
STATE FACILITIES THANK YOU I ASK
FOR YOUR ABOUT.
SOME NUMBER WALDRON FOR WHAT
REASON DO YOU RISE WE OPPOSE
THESE AMENDMENTS FAITH YOU S.
INADEQUATE PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLAND TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES
FORTY TWO NO TWENTY THREE THE
AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE BILL
IS OUT OF PRINT AND BACK ON
FILE.
MOVING TO ITEM THREE NINETY
THREE SB ONE FIFTY TWO MATTER
PARK PLEASE READ SENATE BILL ONE
FIFTY TWO WITH THE MEMBERS BY
SOME REMEMBER WHAT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED
.
MY APOLOGIES MEDI SPEAKER --
AMENDMENTS ON SB ONE FIFTY TWO
WOULD ALLOW VOTERS WITHIN SNOW
MY COUNTY DECIDE WHETHER THEY
WANT TO INCREASE SALES TAX TO
ADDRESS LOCAL NEEDS.
INCREASING THE CURRENT CAPITAL
OUT OF THE LOCAL COMMUNITY
OPTIONS FOR NECESSARY
IMPROVEMENTS TO LOCAL DISASTER
RESPONSE AND RECOVERY
INFRASTRUCTURE.
LEGISLATURE'S GRANTS SIMILAR
EXEMPTIONS TO LOOK COUNTIES IN
S. B. ONE FIFTY TWO IS
CONSISTENT THOSE RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WALDRON WE OPPOSE AMENDMENTS.
META PERK MAY OPEN THE ROLE ALL
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO
MEDICAL CAN MAKE CLOSE THE ROLE
TALLY THE VOTES ICE THIRTY NINE
KNOWS TWENTY FOUR THE AMENDMENTS
ARE ADOPTED THE BILL IS OUT OF
PRINT AND BACK ON FILE.
MOVING TO ITEM THREE NINETY FOUR
SB SEVEN FIFTEEN MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ SEVERAL SEVEN
FIFTEEN WITH A MOMENT BY
SOMETHING [inaudible]
CALDERON THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CERVANTES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AMENDMENTS TO SB SEVEN
FIFTEEN PROVIDE FOR A CHANGE OF
AUTHORSHIP AS WELL AS REMOVING
THE CONTENTS OF THE BILL AND
INSTEAD PROVIDING AN EXEMPTION
FOR CERTAIN REGULATION REGARDING
THE HEAVY EQUIPMENT AND CRANES
UTILIZED.
BY STATE REGISTERED
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS OUR
SPECS WE ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE ON
AMENDMENTS TO BE. TO SEND THE
BILL BACK OUT TO PRINT AND BACK
ON FILE THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WALDRON.
WE OPPOSE THESE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU MADAM CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY.
CLOSE THE ROLAND TALLY THE VOTES
AYE AYES FORTY FIVE KNOWS TWENTY
THREE THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED
THE BILL IS OUT OF PRINT AND
BACK ON FILE
[inaudible]
PROPOSED
.
MISTER CAP MISTER BONTA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER PURSUANT
TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SEVEN
PLEASE RE REFER ITEM NUMBER ONE
FORTY ONE AB TWENTY THREE A
THREE THURMOND. TWO THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER.
MENACE BECAUSE THERE'S A LIST OF
BILLS AT THE DESK WITH FLOOR
AMENDMENTS PENDING.
I ASK THAT THE READING CLERK
READ THE BILLS AND THAT WE ADOPT
THE AMENDMENTS AND THAT THEY GO
OUT TO PRINT AND BACK ON FILE.
HEARING NO OBJECTION BUT APART
PLEASE READ THE BILLS WITH
[inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WALDRON
THAT MOTION.
WELL IT'S THE BACK OKAY.
OKAY HEARING NO OBJECTION MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ THE BILL'S
WITH AMENDMENTS.
BOTTOM ONE FORTY SEVEN SENATE
BILL NINE FIFTY EIGHT WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME THE NUMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY FIVE AND ONE FORTY
NINE SIMPLE FOURTEEN FIFTEEN
WITH AMENDMENTS BY SOME A MEMBER
BONTA.
BOTTOM ONE FIFTY ONE SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN SIXTEEN WITH AMENDMENTS
BY SOME A MEMBER BONTA FILE ITEM
ONE FIFTY TWO SENATE BILL TWO
SEVENTY THREE WITH AMENDMENTS BY
SOME A MEMBER GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
BOTTOM ONE FIFTY FIVE SIMPLE TEN
TWELVE WITH AMENDMENTS BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIMON.
FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY EIGHT SENATE
BILL EIGHT NINETY FOUR WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME NOVEMBER
LEVINE BOTTOM ONE SIXTY SENATE
BILL ELEVEN TWENTY NINE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STONE.
BOTTOM ONE SIXTY THREE SENATE
BILL ELEVEN NINETY FOUR WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME THE MEMBERS
DOWN.
BOTTOM ONE SIXTY FIVE SENATE
BILL SEVEN NINETY WITH
AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LEVINE.
BOTTOM ONE SIXTY EIGHT SENATE
BILL ELEVEN TWENTY EIGHT WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME THE NUMBER
CERVANTES.
BOTTOM ONE SEVENTY THREE SENATE
BILL SEVEN SIXTY FIVE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME NOVEMBER
BLOOM.
BOTTOM ONE EIGHTY ONE SAID
ABOUT.
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN FIVE ONE EIGHT
TWO SAID ABOUT ELEVEN SIXTY
THREE WITH AMENDMENTS BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO.
BY ADAM ONE EIGHTY FIVE SENATE
BILL TEN SEVENTY EIGHT WITH
AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DAVID CHIU.
BOTTOM ONE EIGHTY NINE SENATE
BILL TO NINETY EIGHT WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SUNNY MEMBER
WEBER.
BOTTOM ONE NINETY SENATE BILL
THREE TWENTY SEVEN WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME A MEMBER
IRWIN.
BY ITEM ONE NINETY TWO SENATE
BILL EIGHT TWENTY FOUR WITH
AMENDMENT BY SOME A MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY.
FILE ITEM ONE NINETY FIVE SENATE
BILL TEN ZERO ONE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MULLIN.
BOTTOM ONE NINETY NINE SENATE
BILL TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOMETHING MEMBER
SANTIAGO.
FILE ITEM TWO HUNDRED SAID ABOUT
THIRTEEN THIRTY THREE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME A MEMBER
GLORIA.
BOTTOM TO A ONCE IN ABOUT
THIRTEEN SEVENTY WITH AMENDMENTS
BY SOME A MEMBER GABRIEL.
BOTTOM TOOL FOR SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN FORTY TWO WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME REMEMBER
CUNNINGHAM.
BUYING TO WAIT SAID ABOUT
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOMETHING MEMBER
LOW.
BOTTOM TO LEVINSON ABOUT
THIRTEEN FIFTY EIGHT WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME THE MEMBER
HOLDEN.
BOTTOM TO TWENTY FOUR SENATE
BILL FOURTEEN NINETY SEVEN
CYNICAL FORTY SIX WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME A MEMBER
GLORIA.
BOTTOM TO TWENTY NINE SYMBOL TO
TWELVE WITH AMENDMENTS BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING.
BY AND TWO THIRTY THREE SAID
ABOUT SIX THIRTY FIVE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY CELEBRITIES ALL
ITS FLETCHER.
BOTTOM TO THIRTY FOUR SENATE
BILL SIX FIFTY SIX WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME A MEMBER
COOLEY.
BOTTOM TO THIRTY SEVEN SENATE
BILL EIGHT THIRTY FOUR WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME A MEMBER
MURATSUCHI.
BOTTOM TO FORTY ONE SIMPLE NINE
THIRTY SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIMON.
BOTTOM TO FORTY TWO SAID ABOUT
NINE SIXTY ONE WITH AMENDMENTS
BY SOME A MEMBER GABRIEL.
BOTTOM TO FORTY EIGHT SAID ABOUT
TEN FOURTEEN WITH AMENDMENTS BY
SOME REMEMBER TING.
BOTTOM TO THIRTY NINE CENT BELL
AB TWENTY FIVE WITH AMENDMENTS
BY SOME A MEMBER ARAMBULA.
BOTTOM TO SIXTY TWO SAID ABOUT
ELEVEN FIFTY SIX AT THE MOMENT
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOULD.
BOTTOM TO SIXTY EIGHT SAID ABOUT
WELL TWENTY FIVE AT THE MOMENT
BY SOME REMEMBER ARAMBULA.
FILE IN TWO SEVENTY SENATE BILL
TWELVE SIXTY WITH THE MEMBERS BY
SOME A MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY.
BOTTOM TO ANYONE SAID ABOUT
THIRTY THIRTY NINE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME THE MEMBER
KNOWS AREA AND BOTTOM TO EIGHTY
EIGHT SAMPLE FORTY NINE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME REMEMBER
CABALLERO.
BOTTOM THREE OH ONE SENATE BILL
FIVE SEVENTY NINE WITH THE
MEMBER TWO FORTY FOURTH
AMENDMENT'S ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GLORIA.
BOTTOM THREE A FORCE IN A BILL
OF NO NINE WITH AMENDMENTS BY
SOME A MEMBER ARAMBULA.
BOTTOM THREE OH SEVEN SIMPLE
NINE SIXTY SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS
ARISE ONLY MEMBER ACOSTA.
BOTTOM THREE AWAY SYMBOL NINE
SEVENTY WITH AMENDMENTS BY SOME
A MEMBER SANTIAGO.
BOTTOM THREE TEN SENATE BILL
SIXTY FOUR WITH THE MEMBERS BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES.
BY ON THREE TWELVE SENATE BILL
TWO SEVENTY FIVE WITH AMENDMENTS
BY SOME REMEMBER WOULD.
BOTTOM THREE THIRTEENTHS ABOUT
THREE TWENTY WITH AMENDMENTS BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARILLO.
BOTTOM THREE TEAMS AND BEFORE
FEE SEX AT THE MOMENT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MULLIN.
BOMB THREE EIGHTEEN SYLLABLES
SENATE BILL FIVE THE ONE WITH
THE MOMENT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LOW.
FILE ON THREE TWENTY TWO SENATE
BILL SEVEN HUNDRED WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME A MEMBER
HOLDEN BOTTOM THREE TWENTY THREE
SAID ABOUT SEVENTY SIX AT THE
MOMENT BY SOME REMEMBER CARILLO.
BOTTOM THREE TWENTY FOUR SIMPLE
SEVEN FORTY SIX AT THE MOMENT BY
SOME A MEMBER QUIRK.
BUT ON THREE TWENTY EIGHT SYMBOL
EIGHT THREE NINE WITH AMENDMENTS
BY SOME MEMBER WOULD.
FIND ON THREE THIRTY NINE SENATE
BILL NINE SEVENTY THREE WITH
AMENDMENTS AS ON A MEMBER
LACKEY.
BOTTOM THREE FORTY THREE SAID
ABOUT TEN SEVENTEEN WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME A MEMBER
GLORIA.
FOUND THREE FIFTIES AT ABOUT TEN
THIRTY SEVEN WITH THE BOTTOM
THREE FIFTY SEVEN SENATE BILL
ELEVEN THIRTY ONE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDEN.
BOTTOM THREE SIXTY THREE SENATE
BILL TWELVE FIFTEEN WITH
AMENDMENTS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL.
BOTTOM THREE SIXTY BORIS AND
BILL TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT WITH
AMENDMENTS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLOOM.
FONG THREE SIXTY NINE SAID ABOUT
THIRTY FORTY EIGHT WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME A MEMBER
MEDINA.
BY ON THREE SEVENTIES AT ABOUT
THIRTY SIXTY NINE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOMETHING MEMBER
BURKE.
BOTTOM THREE SEVENTY NINE SENATE
BILL FOURTEEN EIGHTY WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME A BUMPER LOW.
BOTTOM THREE EIGHTY SAMPLE
FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY FROM A MEMBER LOW.
BOTTOM THREE EIGHTY ONE SAID
ABOUT FORTY EIGHTY THREE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME A MEMBER LOW.
BOTTOM THREE EIGHTY FIVE SENATE
BILL TWO THIRTY SEVEN WITH
AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BURKE.
BOTTOM THREE EIGHTY EIGHT SENATE
BILL EIGHT NINETY FIVE
COMMITMENTS BY SUMMING UP THE
KALRA.
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR OF THE
AMENDMENT SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE BILLS ARE
AMENDED OR HOW
TO MEMBERS
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
SEVENTY TWO SEVENTY SEVEN POINT
TWO I AM REFERRING. TO COMMITTEE
THE FOLLOWING BILLS THAT WERE
AMENDED TODAY ITEM ONE FIFTY
FIVE S. B. TEN TWELVE TO HIT THE
HERTZBERG TO HUMAN SERVICES ITEM
ONE SIXTY FIVE S. B. SEVEN
NINETY MCGUIRE TO WATER PARKS
AND WILDLIFE.
SP.
ONE SEVENTY THREE FIRE ITEM OF
ONE SEVENTY THREE SB SEVEN SIXTY
FIVE WIENER TO HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT ITEM OF
ONE EIGHTY ONE AS FOURTEEN FIFTY
NINE CANNELLA. TO AGRICULTURE
AND THEN TO BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS I AM TOO OLD ONE SP
THIRTEEN SEVENTY STERN TO
UTILITIES AND ENERGY ITEM TO
TWENTY NINE SP TWO TWELVE
JACKSON TO ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY
AND TOXIC SUBSTANCES.
AND THEN ON TO APPROPRIATIONS
ITEM TO SEVENTY S. B. TWELVE
SIXTY JACKSON TO THE NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE.
ITEM THREE OH ONE S. B. FIVE
SEVENTY NINE GALGIANI TO RULES
ITEM THREE OH TO S. B. TWO FORTY
FOUR LARA TO PRIVACY AND
CONSUMER PROTECTION.
ITEM THREE ELEVEN SP ONE SIXTY
WIECKOWSKI TO NATURAL RESOURCES
ITEM THREE EIGHTEEN S. B.. FOR
FIFTY SIX PAN TO RULES ITEM
THREE NINETY THREE SB ONE FIFTY
TWO HERNANDEZ TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
ITEM THREE AND NINETY FOUR S. B.
SEVEN FIFTEEN DELGADO TO
TRANSPORTATION
FAMILY RULE
SEVENTY SEVEN TWO I AM RE
REFERRING AT TEN FIFTY FOUR TO
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA YOU'RE
RIGHT YOU'RE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT. TO
SUSPEND JOINT RULE SIXTY TWO A
AND ASSEMBLY WILL FIFTY SIX TO
ALLOW THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE TO HEAR THE FOLLOWING
BILLS.
ON MONDAY S. B. ONE THIRTY FOUR
HERNANDEZ PENDING REFERRAL
MONDAY FROM HUMAN SERVICES S.
BEFORE SIXTY DELI ON PENDING
REFERRAL TODAY FROM PRIVACY
COMMITTEE.
SB SEVEN SEVENTY FOUR LEYVA
PENDING WHAT REFERRAL MONDAY
FROM HIGHER EDUCATION AS WE TALK
THIRTY FIVE GLAZER STR ONE
FOURTEEN STERN.
ACR TWO SIXTY EIGHT VARMINT.
AJ ARE FORTY SEVEN BLOOM.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER THANK YOU PLEASE
RETURN ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY NINE
A. B. SEVEN SIX SEVEN QUIRK
SILVA [inaudible]
THE SENATE [inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION
.
SOME MEMBER BONTA YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I MOVE TO
WAIVE ASSEMBLY RULES.
SEVENTY EIGHT SIXTY THREE AND
SIXTY NINE TO ALLOW SENATE BILL
ONE TWNTY BY THE SENATE BUDGET
AND FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE. TO
BE REMOVED FROM THE INACTIVE
FILE AND TO ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN TO TAKE UP THE BILL FOR
AMENDMENTS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER
.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR THE PURPOSE OF A
MINUTE FOR SENATE BILL.
ONE TWENTY WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER GORY.
SENATE BILL ONE TWENTY WITH
AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
THIS FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANKYOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDING SB.
ONE TWENTY THESE AMENDMENTS
DELETE THE CONTENTS OF THE BILL
AND OUT LANGUAGE THAT WOULD
PROHIBIT THE TRANSFER OF WATER
FROM A GROUND WATER BASIN
UNDERLYING DOESN'T LANDS INTERN
YEAR FEDERAL YEAR STAY PROTECTED
LANDS OUTSIDE OF THE GROUNDWATER
BASIN.
AND LETS THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION IN CONSULTATION WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE FINDS THAT THE TRANSFER
WILL NOT ADVERSELY AFFECT THE
NATURAL CULTURAL RESOURCES OF
THESE LANDS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON THE AMENDMENTS AND THAT THE
BILL BE SENT OUT TO PRINT AND
PUT BACK ON FILE.
THANK YOU SO THE NUMBER FRIEDMAN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED WE OPPOSE THE
AMENDMENTS AND ASK FOR A ROLL
CALL.
THEY GET THE BILL WILL CALL VOTE
ON THIS ITEM.
WITHOUT ANY FURTHER QUESTION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED.
WITHOUT SPREADING BACK ON FILE.
MS MIM MEMBERS MS WALTERS
REQUESTING A ROLL CALL VOTE ON
SENATE BILL.
ONE TWENTY CLICK WILL OPEN THE
WAY.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
THIS IS A MAJORITY OF THOSE
PRESENT AND VOTING.
CLICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
HOW THE VOTE EYES FORTY TWO
KNOWS.
TWENTY THREE THE AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED.
THE BILL IS PLACED OUT DIFFERENT
BACK ON FILE
ABOUT A YEAR
RECOGNIZED FOR MOTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR PLEASE RECALL.
AB TWENTY FOUR NINETY SIX
GONZALEZ FLETCHER FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER
.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO I'M
REFERRING SENATE BILL ONE TWENTY
TO THE NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE
.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT A MAN AMENDMENTS TO
THE S. B..
EIGHT TWENTY EIGHT THESE ARE
OFFERED BY SENATOR WIENER.
THESE AMENDMENTS RESPOND TO
FEEDBACK FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT I'M SO I MADE ABOUT
YOU FOR A MOMENT.
THE CLERK WILL AND IT JUST DIED.
SENATE BILL EIGHT TWENTY EIGHT
WITH THEM ESPECIALLY MEMBER
LEFT.
MR BUT PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU
THAT ACTUALLY.
WITH NOTHING WAS THAT --
I REFER HE MISTER SPEAKER AS I
SAID I RISE TO PRESENT
AMENDMENTS DEATH BE.
EIGHT TWENTY EIGHT AUTHORED BY
SENATOR WIENER THE AMENDMENTS
RESPOND TO FEEDBACK FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT CLARIFY
THAT FINAL DETERMINATIONS MADE
PRIOR TO THE DATE OF ENACTMENT.
SHALL NOT BE REVISED THEY MAKE
TECHNICAL IN CLARIFYING CHANGES
AS WELL.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM.
MISS WALDRON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
WE OPPOSE THE AMENDMENTS
[inaudible]
VERY GOOD.
WILLOW ASKED THE CLERK TO PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED
ABOUT.
THERE IS A MAJORITY OF THOSE
PRESENT AND VOTING ON MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
QUICKLY IS CLOSE THE ROLE IN TO
HOW YOU VOTE EYES THIRTY EIGHT
KNOWS.
TWENTY THREE THE MINUTES ARE
ADOPTED.
DOES NOT A TREND BACK ON FILE.
THANK YOU STEPHEN
YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE.
SIXTY NINE TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHAO TO TAKE UP LATE
AMENDMENTS TO ITEM.
ONE SIXTY TWO S. B. ELEVEN
TWENTY ONE DOT.
IS WALDRON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED WE
OPPOSE THAT MOTION.
AND THAT'S A MISS WALDRON IS
ASKING FOR A ROLL CALL VOTE
[inaudible]
THE THERE'S A MOTION BY MISTER
BONTA SECONDED BY MISTER GIPSON.
IT TAKES FORTY ONE VOTES THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
I'M MEMBERS VOTED IS VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
QUICK OPPOSE THE ROLE AND HOW
THEY VOTE AYE AYES FORTY EIGHT
KNOWS.
TWENTY FOUR THE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED
.
SENATE BILL ELEVEN TWENTY ONE
PERMISSION WAS GRANTED. TO AMEND
THE BILL.
THE CLERK WILL READ SENATE
ELEVEN TWENTY ONE WITH THE
MEMBERS BY THE NAME OF A CHILD.
MISTER CHAO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS SO.
S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY ONE MAKES A
VARIETY OF TECHNICAL CORRECTIONS
TO AB THREE SEVENTY FIVE FIVE AS
FOLLOWS. ONE THEY CLARIFIED THE
EXISTING HIPAA AND
CONFIDENTIALITY OF MEDICAL
INFORMATION ACT EXCEPTION IN THE
BILL. TO THEY CLARIFIED THE
EXISTING EXCEPTIONS.
TO THE PERSONAL INFORMATION
COLLECTED OR THIS CLOSE PURSUANT
TO THE FEDERAL GRAHAM LEACH
BLILEY ACT AND THE DRIVER
PRIVACY PROTECTION ACT.
AND EXPRESSLY SPECIFIED THAT
NEITHER OF THOSE EXCEPTIONS
APPLY TO SECTION OF AB THREE
SEVENTY FIVE RELATED TO DATA
BREACHES. THREE THEY CLARIFY THE
NEW SCATTERING EXCEPTIONS BY
SPECIFYING THAT THE RIGHTS
AFFORDED TO CONSUMERS AND THE
OBLIGATIONS IMPOSED ON ANY
BUSINESS UNDER AB.
THREE SEVENTY FIVE SHALL NOT BE
CONSTRUED TO APPLY TO THE EXTENT
THAT THEY INFRINGE ON THE NON
COMMERCIAL ACTIVITIES OF CERTAIN
PERSONS WHICH INCLUDE AMONG
OTHERS A PUBLISHER.
EDITOR OR REPORTER [inaudible]
FOR THEY CLARIFIED THAT THE
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION IN THIS
BILL APPLIES ONLY TO DATA
BREACHES AS SPECIFIED. FIVE THEY
CLARIFIED THAT THE PREEMPTION
CLAUSE OF AB THREE SEVENTY FIVE
IS TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY OR
US THE REST OF THE BILL HE'S
OPERATE OF JANUARY FIRST. TWENTY
TWENTY SIX THE AMENDMENTS ALSO
AMEND THE PROVISIONS RELATING TO
ENFORCEMENT BY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO REMOVE REFERENCE. TO
THE UNFAIR COMPETITION LAW AND
ELIMINATE THE EIGHTY TWENTY
SPLIT.
AND HOW CIVIL PENALTIES ARE TO
BE ALLOCATED.
AND REQUIRED THE AG TO ADOPT
REGULATIONS TO FURTHER THE
PURPOSES OF AB THREE SEVENTY
FIVE BY JULY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY INSTEAD OF JANUARY
FIRST. TWENTY TWENTY SEVENTY
EIGHT YEARS PRECLUDED FROM
BRINGING AN ENFORCEMENT ACTION
UNDER AB THREE SEVENTY FIVE
UNTIL SIX MONTHS.
AFTER THE PUBLICATION OF THE
FINAL REGULATIONS ISSUED
PURSUANT TO THIS SECTION OR JULY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY WHICHEVER IS
SOONER.
AND FINALLY THE AMENDMENTS ADDED
URGENCY CLAUSE AND MAKE OTHER
TECHNICAL OR CLARIFYING CHANGES.
WITH A I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO
SEEN NO OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO
SPEAK.
ON THE SIDE OF THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE.
ON THE AMENDMENTS THEM MEMBERS
PLEASE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
MEMBERS GOT MISS ON THE
AMENDMENTS.
QUICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY TWO
NO.
ZERO THE MINUTES ARE DOT.
DOT DIDN'T THE THE BILL HAS.
HOW TO PRINT AND PUT BACK ON
FILE?
I PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO I AM RE
REFERRING --
ITEM ONE SIXTY TWO SENATE BILL
ELEVEN TWENTY ONE DODD TO THE
PRIVACY CONSUMER TEXAN COMMITTEE
AND THEN TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
ALSO I'M REVISING THEM EARLIER
RE REFER ALL OF SENATE BILL TWO
FORTY FOUR LARA TO DO TO ADD THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
AFTER THE BILL IS HEARD IN THE
PRIVACY AND CONSUMER PROTECTION
COMMITTEE
.
I MEMBERS THE FOLLOWING
COMMITTEES WILL BE MEETING UPON
ADJOURNMENT OF SESSION
TRANSPORTATION IN ROOM.
FOUR THIRTY SEVEN CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE ON SENATE BILL NINE OH
ONE IN ROOM.
FORTY TWO OH TWO THE SESSION SET
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS MONDAY
AUGUST TWENTY SEVENTH FLOOR
SESSION FROM ONE PM TO SIX PM
.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAIN WILL BE
PASSED IN RETAINS ALL EXCEPT OUR
MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUED.
MEMBERS WE HAVE NO ADJOURNMENTS
IN MEMORY THIS THIS MORNING SO
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTER.
BUSINESS MEMBERS I'M READY TO
ADJOURN --
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN
MISTER BONTA MOVES MAYES RUBIO
SECONDS.
THE REST THE HOUSE THIRDS OF
WHEAT HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL MONDAY AUGUST TWENTY SEVEN
AT ONE PM THE QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED WE ARE JOURNAL